hey did you know that there was a Dragon
Ball Blu-ray release this year that is
better than literally every other
Blu-ray or footage of Dragon Ball in
existence just this year out of nowhere
a company in France of all places named
a b group put together a release that
has put everything before to shame
original 4-3 aspect ratio so no lost
footage from being zoomed in faithful
color correction to have the colors
match as they were originally intended
to be aired original broadcast audio and
that means that the Japanese voices
actually don't sound like they're coming
from a tin can
[Music]
and finally an upscale that bombs the
overall resolution and Clarity way
way the last one is really worth talking
about because a lot of the time AI
upscales can completely suck but it's
clear that whatever team was in charge
of this release over an AB group really
knows Dragon Ball very well the footage
speaks for itself